High doctor cutters I started using my wife six days ago. After two nights I started to have what I would describe as stomach ache constantly.
I had also started my cycle during that time, so some of the pain was consistent with that pain.
But I, but it lingered days past what is usual.
So I remember, uh, what's my cancer? Okay. Uh, all right.
So I had also started my cycle, Liger days past because several bowel movements during these days as well.
I also started to have shoulder pain in my left shoulder where I had pain post surgery due to the gases in my stomach.
So if you had shoulder pain post surgery, uh, due to the gases in your stomach in your left shoulder, I'd highly suggest that's due to your gallbladder.
A gallbladder will refer pain to your left shoulder. So, um, first of all, I would say, uh, just giving this information here.
Coffee animals are gotta be your friend. You've got to start doing coffee animals.
You are, if the, if you are getting pain post doing the right machine, you're probably detoxing and it may be getting blocked in your gallbladder.
Coffee animals are going to be your friend. Also hot packs over your liver.
So getting hot packs over your liver in the next step would be castor oil packs over your liver with a hot pack over the castor oil pack.
Definitely felt off all around. Yep. You're probably detoxing. I had read that you see the right for cause you to first feel worse or symptoms before you feel better.
It doesn't, it may be, maybe only about 20% of the time that really does happen.
So, but that's probably what you're feeling. It's really signs of a blocked gallbladder hot packs over your liver.
You're going to be kidding your gallbladder that way. Tricky lots of water trying to flush out your gallbladder.
Even some, uh, some massage under your right rib cage to try to get your gallbladder moving. That would be also helpful.
Those are the things that I would think of first.
Doing multiple coffee animals per day, definitely. So that will really help that getting that flow going.